[تصفيق]
شكرًا لاستضافتي آه شكرًا على
المقدمة، أنا أتحدث اللغة الإنجليزية الأسوأ
بين أي شخص في أي لجنة ولكن آه مورغان
سوف يطرح بعض الأسئلة خلال دقيقة واحدة ولكن
أريد أن أقول شيئًا عن
البلد المضيف الذي أحسنت أه في كأس العالم
أحسنت إذا كنت بحاجة إلى مكيف هواء في أي وقت، فأنا
أعرف أي بلد
سأتصل به، لقد كان صديقًا لي
منذ عقود، وقد التقيت به من خلال
صديقي العزيز جون ماكين منذ سنوات مضت بيننا
خلافاتنا ولكني أريد فقط أن أشكر
بلاده  أهل الحضيض
لمساعدتنا في
أفغانستان، هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين تمكنوا من الخروج بسبب
ما فعلتموه، أريد أن أشكركم على
العمل لمحاولة
إطلاق سراح الرهائن، هناك الكثير من الناس خرجوا
من وضع رهيب  بسبب ما
فعلته، تعرضت لبعض
الانتقادات وحماس هنا ولكني أعرف
سبب وجودهم هنا، إنهم هنا حتى
يمكن التحدث إليهم والقيام بأشياء أه
للعالم والتي في بعض الأحيان لا تحظى
بشعبية كبيرة ولكني أريد فقط  لأعلمك
أنني أقدر ما تفعله، وأحب
المجيء إلى هنا،
وأنت الحل أكثر من
المشكلة